les Chinois n'ont pas tout à fait la
même stratégie que les Russes il y a ils
sont beaucoup inspirés des Russes mais
leur stratégie reste en partie
différentes
les Russes mis en beaucoup plus sur la
le qualitatif lors d'une manière
générale leurs opérations
d'informationnelles sont beaucoup plus
subtiles
pas toujours mais en moyenne disons
les Chinois mis en plus sur la quantité
par exemple depuis à peu près 2-3 ans
les contenus rediffusés
les contenus produits par qnon aux
États-Unis et rediffuser sur les réseaux
sociaux le sont plus souvent par la
Chine que par la Russie c'était pas le
cas par exemple
il y a 4 ou 5 ans aujourd'hui les
chinois sont plus actifs que les Russes
en matière de diffusion des théories du
complot information manipulées etc par
les réseaux qui ont aux États-Unis donc
il y a une stratégie qui est quand même
basée sur sur le quantitatif quitte à
diffuser des produits beaucoup moins
sophistiqués parce que il s'appuie aussi
sur un certain nombre de d'avancées des
sciences cognitives par exemple on sait
aujourd'hui que plus on est exposé à une
information même si c'est une
information fausse plus le cerveau a
tendance à croire à cette information
donc c'est pas tant la enfin c'est pas
seulement la qualité de l'information
qualité de son de la manipulation de
l'information si vous voulez mais tout
simplement le degré auquel vous êtes
exposé à cette information
donc donc ça les Chinois en tiennent
compte dans leur dans leur
opérations informationnelles de la même
manière bien évidemment il y a c'est
c'est ces opérations informationnelles
font sens entre elles elles sont liées
entre elles et donc on renvoie de l'une
à l'autre par exemple dans le rapport on
a évoqué la question de
l'opération
appelée infection 2.0 donc autour de la
covid 19 et la volonté des Chinois de
faire croire que les États-Unis a fait
fabriquer le virus du Sark of 2 ils ont
ciblé dans cette opération une base qui
est la base de Ford détruits aux
États-Unis et c'est la base qui avait
déjà été ciblée par le KGB en 1983 dans
le cas de l'opération infection et donc
cette base avait été accusée d'avoir
fabriqué le virus du sida pour décimer
les populations afro-américaines et gay
aux États-Unis
le fait que les Chinois utilisent un
certain nombre de référents qui sont des
référents puissants
des théories du complot montre que la
sophistication n'est pas toujours utile
puisque en mettant quelques mots clés
quelques quelques référents clés et bien
on n'a pas besoin de plus de
sophistication que ça ça suffit à faire
sens et à renvoyer à un imaginaire
puissant du complot
en l'occurrence américain